Hi.
In this video, we're going to
compute some useful quantities
for the exponential
random variable.
So we're given that x is
exponential with rate lambda.
PDF looks like this, and
the formula is here.
First question, part
a, what's the CDF?
So let's go right in.
The CDF of x is the probability
that X is less
than or equal to little x.
Let's look at some cases here.
What if little x
is less than 0?
Well, x random variable
only takes on these
non-negative values.
And so the probability that X is
less than or equal to some
negative number is
going to be 0.
On the other hand, if x is
greater than or equal to 0, we
do actually have to
integrate here.
So to do that, we take the
integral from minus infinity
to x of fx of t--
the dummy variable
here used is t.
Notice that again, fx of t is
going to be 0 for negative
values, so we take the
integral here from 0.
And now we plug in
for fx of t.
That's minus lambda t dt.
And recall that the integral
of u to the a t is 1 over a
times e to the a t.
So here in this case,
we'll get lambda,
which is just a constant.
And then a here is going
to be negative lambda.
So we get this, 0 to x.
Lambdas cancel and we actually
get 1 minus e to the
minus lambda x.
So do this.
And we are done with the CDF.
Now for the expectation.
We use the standard formula,
which is minus infinity to
infinity t times fx of t dt.
So again, fx of t is going to
be 0 for a negative value.
So we do the integral from 0.
We get 0 to infinity t lambda
e to the minus lambda t dt.
Now, you can try all you want
to get rid of this t.
It's not going to go even if
you try all kinds of u
substitution.
But at the end the day, you're
going to have to pull out your
calculus textbook and find
the integration by parts
formula, which is--
v du.
So the hope is that this
integral is going to be easier
than the one on the left.
Notice that this is the
integral of one
of the terms here.
And this is the derivative
of one of the terms.
So that may help you decide
on how you select u and v.
In our case actually, I'm
going to use u as--
t for u.
Because when you take
the derivative, it's
going to become 1.
And the derivative is what's
going to go in that integral.
So this is going to
be dt for du.
And then, dv I'm going
to select as
whatever's left over.
It's lambda e to minus
lambda t dt.
So v is going to be--
we already did the integral--
minus e to the minus lambda t.
And so if we do this, it's going
to be negative t times e
to the minus lambda t.
So that's uv.
Minus v, which is negative
e to the minus
lambda t times dt.
That goes from 0 to infinity.
This is evaluated from
0 to infinity.
Well, what does it mean
for this to be
evaluated from 0 to infinity?
A better and easier way to look
at this is to say, well,
it's going to go from 0 to x.
But then you take the limit
as x goes to infinity.
So that's going to
help us here.
And this negative--
these negatives cancel.
And we're left with--
let's plug in the bounds.
We're left with negative x
minus lambda x plus the
integral of this is going to be
1 over negative lambda e to
the minus lambda t evaluated
from 0 to infinity.
All right, so now the limit.
So for the limit, notice
that x increases
as x goes to infinity.
And this exponential decays.
So they're kind of competing
for each other.
But the exponential is going to
win because it decays way
faster than x.
And so this first term
is going to go off--
the limit is going to go to 0.
All right.
For this, if you evaluate
the balance, the
infinity makes this 0.
And 0, you're going to
get 1 over lambda.
So that's 1 over lambda.
All right.
And so the expectation
is 1 over lambda.
OK, so now what's
the variance?
That's part c, right?
So we use the standard formula
for variance, which is this.
We already figured out
the expectation.
We just need to figure out the
expectation of x squared.
Well, we're just going to follow
the same set of steps
from before.
For x squared, it's just going
to be t squared, t squared, t
squared, x squared.
The only thing that's going to
change is what we choose for u
here, for the u substitution.
So it's going to be t squared.
So the derivative is going
to change to 2t dt.
v is going to be exactly
the same.
And so here in this term, we
get negative 2t e to the
minus lambda t.
But there's a negative sign
out here, so the negatives
cancel and we're left with
a positive sign here.
This is going to change.
All right.
OK.
So in order to do this integral,
we can use a trick.
We can move this--
so there's a 2t here.
We move this 2 in here,
leave the t inside.
And you have to leave
the t inside.
But multiply by lambda
and divide by lambda.
Now, look at that integral.
0 to infinity t times lambda
e to the minus lambda t dt.
Exactly the expectation
that we computed.
We already did that.
That is just 1 over lambda, so
it's 2 over lambda times 1
over lambda.
Again, the limit as x
goes to infinity--
the exponential will
beat x squared.
No matter what polynomial
we put in there, the
exponential's going to win.
So this is going
to be 0 still.
This one's going to be 2
over lambda squared.
So we're left with 2 over lambda
squared for expectation
of x squared.
And so we have 1 over lambda
squared for the variance.
OK, so we're done with
the variance.
Part d.
We're given that x1, x2, and
x3 are independent and
identically distributed.
They're exponentials
with rate lambda.
We're asked for the PDF
of z, which is the max
of x1, x2, and x2.
How do we generally
find a PDF?
We take the CDF and then take
the derivative, right?
We first find the CDF, and
then take the derivative.
So let's do that.
So first, let's see.
Part d, find the CDF of z,
which is going to be the
probability that Z is less than
or equal to little z,
which is going to be equal to
the probability that the max
of x1, x2, x3 is less
than or equal to z.
And this is going to have
the same sort of
structure as before.
If z is less than 0, x1,
x2, x3 are positive--
non-negative.
And so this is the probability
that if you get little z less
than 0, you're not going to have
any probability there.
And so if z is greater than or
equal to 0 is where it gets
interesting.
We need to do something
special.
So the special thing here
is to recognize that the
probability of the max being
less than or equal to z is
actually also the probability
of each of these random
variables individually being
less than or equal to z.
Why is that true?
One way to check whether the
events-- these two events are
the same is to check
the two directions.
One direction say, if the max of
x1, x2, x3 is less than or
equal to z, does that mean x1 is
less than or equal to z, x2
is less than or equal
to z, and x3 is less
than or equal to z?
Yes.
OK.
And then, if x1, x2, and x3 are
individually less than or
equal to z, then the max is also
less than or equal to z.
So these two events are
equivalent and this is true.
By independence we can
break this up.
And we get--
these are all CDFs of the
exponential and they
all have this form.
So it's just going to
be 1 minus e to the
minus lambda z cubed.
Plug this in here.
And then, try to take the
derivative to get the PDF.
Let's see.
So it's going to be the same,
like this for z less than 0.
For z greater than or equal
to 0, it's going to be the
derivative of this thing.
Derivative of this thing is by
chain rule, 3 times 1 minus e
to the minus lambda z squared.
Then the derivative of negative
e to the minus lambda
z, that's just lambda e
to the minus lambda z.
There we go.
This is the PDF we
were looking for.
So last problem.
We're looking for the PDF
of w, which is the
min of x1 and x2.
So let's try this as
a similar approach.
Try the same thing, actually.
See if it works.
So w, w, w, w, min, less
than or equal to w.
OK.
So let's see if this works.
Is it true that the min--
if the min of x1 and x2 is less
than or equal to w, that
each of them is less
than or equal to w?
No, right?
X1 could be less than or
equal to w and x2 could
be bigger than w.
And the min could still be
less than or equal to w.
So that's definitely not true.
So what do we do here?
The trick is to flip it and say
we want to compute the min
of x1 and x2 being
greater than w.
In that case, let's check
if we can do this trick.
If the min of x1 and x2 is
greater than w, then clearly
x1 is bigger than w and
x2 is bigger than w.
And if x1 and x2 are
individually bigger than w,
then clearly the min's
also bigger than w.
So this works.
And now we can use independence
as before.
And for this, this is just
1 minus the CDF here.
So it's just going to be
e to the minus lambda
w for each of them.
But that's the same as e
to the minus lambda 2w.
Or e to the 2 lambda w.
So it's going to be--
Notice the similarity between
this and this.
The only difference is this
has a 2 lambda in there.
That means that w is an
exponential random variable
with rate 2 lambda.
So then the PDF is going to be
an exponential, whatever it is
for an exponential.
Except with rate 2 lambda.
You can also take the derivative
of this and find
that you get this.
OK, so we're done with
the problems.
We computed some interesting
quantities for the exponential
random variable in this--